bonjour à tous j'ai souhaité vous
adresser mes voeux pour ces fêtes de fin
d'année depuis ma ville du puy en velay
en vous faisant partager cette image
absolument magnifique de ce qu'est le
paysage de la ville du puy je voulais
adresser à chacun d'entre vous mes
meilleurs voeux pour ces fêtes de fin
d'année et pour la nouvelle année qui va
venir en ayant bien sûr une pensée toute
particulière pour ceux qui ont subi des
épreuves ou qui passeront s'est fait
seuls les fêtes c'est lé moment pour se
retrouver pour partager de la joie mais
aussi pour avoir une pensée pour ceux
qui ont moins de chance la france a une
chance extraordinaire
notre pays a des atouts que peu de pays
mais ma conviction c'est que pour les
valoriser
nous devons retrouver aussi les valeurs
qui nous ont toujours permis d'avancer
le sens du travail de l'effort du mérite
mais aussi les valeurs de respect de
laïcité qui ont parfois été si malmenés
au cours de cette année 2010 est pour
que la france rayonne
elle doit se remettre la tête à
l'endroit ray assumer défendre ses
valeurs
dans ce cadre là vous le savez je veux
reconstruire la parole de la droite
[Musique]
nous avons perdu et nous avons beaucoup
déçu nous avons même parfois écoeuré les
français je veux qu'on sonne nouvelle
droite avec des nouveaux visages
une nouvelle génération tout changer et
surtout tirer les leçons des erreurs du
passé
mon souhait surtout de pouvoir rpt et
offrir aux français un choix faire en
sorte que face à emmanuel macron il est
une opposition
une opposition qui ne soit pas sectaire
une opposition qui soit ouverte à
soutenir tout ce qu'il ira dans la bonne
direction mais une opposition qui
défendent aussi ses valeurs et qui ne
fasse pas un chèque en blanc
quand il ya des fautes et des erreurs
qui sont commises pour l'avenir de la
france et des français à la rentrée
malheureusement les retraités les
familles les classes moyennes vont à
nouveau payer une lourde addition
avec des impôts qui vont augmenter de
plus de 4 5 milliards d'euros
parce qu'il n'y a pas de vraies
économies sur le gaspillage de l'argent
public
mon premier combat sera de défendre les
classes moyennes les retraités face à
l'augmentation de la csg
le deuxième sujet sur lequel toute notre
communauté nationale doit être uni c'est
la défense de nos valeurs de laïcité de
l'identité de notre pays face aux
communautarismes et face aux attaques du
terrorisme notre pays a trop souvent été
endeuillée dans les années qui se sont
écoulées pour prendre le moindre risque
et je ne peux pas accepter qu'on laisse
revenir en france
des jihadistes qui sont partis en syrie
ou en irak
le président de la république a expliqué
qu on les laisserait revenir au cas par
cas
je pense que c'est une erreur et nous
défendrons tout au long de cette année
avec fermeté les dossiers de sécurité
qui permettront de protéger les français
et puis enfin il faut que notre économie
puisse retrouver son dynamisme son
énergie soutenir tous ceux qui
travaillent
arrêtez de les assommer de charge on ne
peut pas continuer avec un pays dans
lequel au fond celui qui travail n'est
pas récompensé de ses efforts que ce
soit un entrepreneur un artisan un
commerçant ou que ce soit un salarié qui
travaille au smic et qui souvent
constate qu'ils ne gagnent pas plus que
s'il reste chez lui à toucher les
prestations sociales
dans ce cadre là il faut aussi avoir le
courage de dire clairement que notre
pays ne pourra pas continuer à
accueillir autant d'immigrés le
gouvernement à reculer sur ces questions
sur la fin de l'année la voix de la
droite défendera clairement l'idée que
nous n'avons plus les mêmes capacités
d'intégration que celle de la fin des
années 70 avec les difficultés
économiques qui sont les nôtres
ce serait une folie d'accueillir trop de
personnes auxquelles nous ne pouvons pas
offrir un vrai avenir
oui la france a des talents je veux que
nous puissions regarder vers l'avenir
avec confiance
mais pour cela il faut aussi restaurer
le débat démocratique
faire en sorte que les choix soient
posés sur la table que les français
soient aussi défendu dans leurs
priorités et dans leur vie quotidienne
ce sera mon combat pour une nouvelle
droite
engagé aux côtés des français et qui
défendent cette idée simple la france ne
doit pas renoncer à ce qu'elle est la
france doit retrouver tout ce qui a fait
son énergie et son talent meyer fait à
chacun d'entre vous
[Musique]